I'm going to show you a mathematical
magic trick which is going to incredible
so if you'd like to take a card out I
can take any cards you like
I won't look at it we can show the
camera okay cool so you're putting oh
we're going to put it in the pack but
the idea is using maths alone I'm going
to shuffle your card to anywhere you
like in the pack I'm going to do perfect
perfect mathematical shuffles I'm going
to take it anywhere you like in the pack
so you could say 43 and was five or less
shuffles I could take it to the 43rd
card for example so what what number
would you like I'll write it down let's
go for 22 22 okay if I write it down
here and then we won't forget it I
reckon I could do it in four shuffles
each shuffle I'm going to know exactly
where it is with math and then I'll
explain to you how it happened
so exactly one after the other so
basically
do it's one or the other okay and I'm
going to myself three more and then it
should be at the twenty second card for
three more shuffles it's like threading
fifty-two needles at once it's very
tense that's a perfect shuffle two more
shuffles two more peppy shuffles and
hopefully I'll have found your card
exactly the 22nd place that's a perfect
shuffle that's good enough for me one
off the other the one one I laid them
out so you can see it's definitely
perfect and just see though they're
perfect I sure can see it's exactly one
after the other
yep so let's group them together
whoops ladies 22nd card you ready I'm
really I'm really waiting okay
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 19 20 21 was your card ace of clubs
ace of clubs isn't that magical by the
power of mathematics
I'm going to explain it with let's take
some of the hearts out so ok I'm going
to put these on the top of the pack in
order 6 5 4 3 2 1 now what I've done is
just to demonstrate it a little bit I
put the hearts on the top the first
seven just so you can kind of follow
what happens in a perfect shuffle
there's two ways I can perfectly shuffle
the cards like this you might think
there's one way but there's two ways I
can do it first way it's going to look
like this so this is the first way I've
done it and if I spread it out you'll
see if I just look at the hearts what's
happened to them the number of cards
above every card has doubled so above
the seven that was originally six and
now there's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
above the four that was originally three
and now there's 1 2 3 4 5 6 ok so this
doubles the number of cards above every
card in the top half of the pack if I'm
going to write it here if there was any
cards above it after the shuffle there
was two end cards above it and because
this doesn't affect where the top card
was it doesn't do anything I'm just
going to call it a zero shuffle that's
the name of that shuffle now that's
let's say if I cut them the pack in half
like this and I shuffled them like this
so this top card stayed on top the
second where I could shuffle image I
could shuffle it like this so the top
card would be now be second from the top
so it looks something whoops it would
look something like this ok so what this
does it doesn't just double the number
of cards above every card it doubles it
in adds one so above the 5 there were
four cards another there's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 it's doubled it another one above
the four there was three cards and has 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 so what this shuffle does if
there was any cards above it afterwards
there's going to be too lots of N and an
extra one and this now changes the
position of the top card it does
something to it so I'm going to call it
a1 like it does something to to that
top card it changed the place now we're
ready to explain to you how I got your
cards to 22nd card basically to begin
with you might have seen or maybe not
I'm not sure that when I took your card
back I'm secretly moved it to the top of
the pack I don't see I did I see we move
the top of the pack how do you do it was
where it's coming like this I put it in
and I pretended to a shirt show it to
you like this
they're in the pack and then I sprinkle
it but now it's there on top I still
don't see how you did that well that's
the bit you're gonna have to practice
maybe so some of the top of the pack you
could you could do it any way you want
you could even tell them to just put it
on the top so maybe maybe you might have
thought it was in the middle but
actually was on the top of the pack so
allit when it's on the top of the pack
it's got no cards above it if we want it
ender the 22nd place let me cover this
up and 22nd place it needs to have 21
cards above it so all I've got to work
out is what sequence of doubling
shuffles and doubling that one shuffles
I need to do so 21 on number so I must
have doubled something and added one I
must have doubled 10 and added one okay
and that was a 1 shuffle it was a
shuffle that doubled an added one so
this is a number one here na RA
that's a 1 times an even number unless
it's doubled 5 to get to 10 so that was
a doubling shuffle there's a 0 shuffle
that 2 n 2 2 n this is an odd number
again so I must have doubled something
added one I must have doubled to and
added 1 so that shuffle layer is the
doubling add 1 shuffle which we labeled
as at 1 that's an even number so before
having 2 cards above it I must have had
one card above it and that also been the
doubling shuffle and then to get from 0
to 1
I must have doubled 0 and then added 1
so that was a 1 shuffle so where the 1
shuffle is the shuffle why doubled the
number of cards above every card and
added 1 so this is double 0 add 1 a 0
shuffle is when I double the number of
cards above above every card so here had
one card above it and after that after
that shuffle it had 2 cards above it and
then the 1 shuffle I double the amount
of cards
every card and they added one at zero
shuffle I doubled the amount of cards
above every card and the one shuffle I
double the amount of cards above it and
added one when I say every card I mean
every card in the top of the pack took
half the pack which is where your card
is at the moment is that one you will
list about yeah where's the bottom part
didn't work out it was okay cuz I knew
your card starts at the top and was just
working its way downwards so the bottom
half didn't really matter so you're
telling me when you you knew the ace of
clubs at the top yeah so as soon as that
was the case you you you had to do a 1
shuffle a 0 shuffle a 1 shuffle is
Eurasian open a window yeah but there's
a there's a way to work it out so this
is so this is 1 0 1 0 1 and actually
this is just a binary number and if I
draw in what the values of each column
are this is the number of ones this is
the number of two's this is fours 8 16 s
because that's how you count in binary
so actually this is a 16 a 4 and 1 this
is this is the number 21 in binary so I
just have to work out what your number
is in binary do that seems of shuffles
and it will take it's the right place
so if someone I'm watching at home wants
to do this trick to their friends or
parents yeah there are there's still a
lot of barriers here they have to
understand binary which is maybe one of
the easier steps yeah they have to be
able to do perfect shuffles as true and
they have to be able to do the sleight
of hand to get the card up to the top
yeah well the binary I mean sometimes I
don't trust myself to work out the
binary so have it written somewhere on a
piece of paper just in case to get them
to get the card to the top you could do
loads of things you have the ace of
clubs didn't you I mean you could do to
get the card at the top you could say
they take our card and you can say say
stop and they say stop somewhere and
they put it in here but say you remember
what the bottom card is if they say stop
that you put it in here you know once
you cut this in it's going to be
underneath that card so it looks like
you kind of mixed in but you know it's
going to be underneath the two of spades
and you can go I'm looking for the
garden looking for the gutter I don't
know where it is you could split it and
bring it there and then it's on top so
lots of ways that don't take sleight of
hand to bring it the top to do the
shuffling if you want to do that way you
would have to practice it or you could
just take take them to to house and deal
them out one by one if you wanted to
make a trick was like they were made a
trick quite slow it's quite nice to
practice it and maybe maybe that's
something to aim for